how did your family take it when you
were new we'll go back to you if you
have more questions bro sorry I got a
ton more but yeah it's your podcast I'll
let you take over but I respect it homie
okay how um
how did they initially take it though
um my mom and I like I don't my dad's
never been in my life
um and then my mom and I have like a
pretty rocky relationship just in
general
um so she like tried to be supportive
but there's definitely been periods
where she's like I don't like that
you're doing this I don't like the
lifestyle that you're living like can
you just get a normal job this type of
thing and I'm like this is making me
happy right now so I'm gonna stick with
it and then if I want a job in the
future that's why I went and got my
degree so I can have that I have that
safety net to fall back on would you
describe your future husband as a
masculine man yeah he's very competitive
yeah super so how do you justify that
being you know a competitive man but
then also the one thing that he would
have with you that would be just you in
a relationship is something that people
can pay to see how does he justify that
if you could speak yeah I mean at the
end of the day they don't own me they
neither does he but he knows that he's
the only man I want to be with he's the
only man I love and we're just selling
like an experience like you're not
actually in the room with us you're not
actually seeing us have like very deep
intimate
you're seeing like the fun more playful
things where we know we're recording and
it's just like okay let's have some fun
and it's totally fine do you guys plan
on getting a prenup no
so he works with you and your business
so my assumption is is that you are the
breadwinner so yeah we make about the
same
my money is my money even though he's on
camera with me it's completely my money
he has his own separate job and we make
about this what does he do he's a
bartender how does he make as much as
you do because I don't make that much
right now I only do only part time so
interesting yeah okay okay the whole
prenup thing is definitely something to
be concerned about for him but hey so be
it whatever makes him happy yeah I think
uh did you did you get a printout me no
really you got three businesses my g i
all started them all after we got
married
oh so you know I went into the map I
went to the marriage with nothing we
built everything basically together you
know obviously she's somebody that's
always been able to fall back to it's
almost worse than actually why because
she can take half of your businesses I
mean like I hope she doesn't you know it
seems it seems like you guys it's a post
Merit that I mean then you need a
post-marriage agreement not a priest
number yeah so you can do prenups where
you say that I was just talking to the
lead attorney about this you can do
prenups like where it says that like it
whatever assets you acquire like they're
not entitled yeah but I don't think
about it like that because the reality I
mean God forbid we don't get divorced
and it's not from like some shitty
situation but like
you know why would I take away half of
what she's technically helped me to
build you know she's had a she's had a
steady job throughout all my ups and
downs business world is really a roller
coaster you know you take hits you take
take wins I mean there's days that I've
lost a lot of [__] money that it
hurts you don't think you would have
been able to build what you've built
without a wife
I probably could have but at the end of
the day it would take it's not that
I wouldn't have been able to build a
family you know build the kind of
lifestyle that I wanted
um without a wife and she was obviously
been there I'm not I don't I'm not
somebody that looks in my past and I'm
like regretful of anything you know it
brought me to where I am today and thank
God you know I have a beautiful family
and you know I'm great businesses that
are all you know doing well and growing
so by like I'm not gonna explain yeah I
think it's actually to an earlier
conversation about part of the argument
why men might wait because from a
financial perspective
waiting building business however is it
that takes you to be able to prenup that
so that if things were go to Rye and you
know I'm not wishing that on you but
um if it did then at least you'd have
that separation between when you got
married and when you started the
marriage but you know there's also too a
um you know you wouldn't have been able
to build a family at the same time as
well darn it I mean imagine getting to
be like 55 60 she leaves takes half of
the businesses you don't have the energy
to restart yeah but hey I mean if I got
divorced ever I'm never getting married
again period it's just it's a lot of
work but it's you know it's a lot of
enjoyable work but I wouldn't do it
again especially not at 50 things it's
time to prenup if you ask 100 okay
um like I don't know thank God she's a
very cool girl I love her
um probably could never marry anybody
else just a fact you know dated a lot of
girls been with a lot of girls she's
thank God the one for me what do you
think is like for like men today if you
were to say listen these are the
benefits of marriage
like what are the things that you think
that you would tell
the one for me is she actually is my
best friend we travel the [__] world
together you know a lot of people can't
do that with their significant others
because they don't actually enjoy
hanging out with them um but like we go
into Costa Rica we went ziplining we I
mean we've done two cruises we've
traveled to uh different parts of South
America Central America Europe Middle
East so like
somebody that you can actually hang out
with is huge but you obviously have to
get along with them and then B having
somebody that you can actually share and
build with
um is a huge thing you know can could I
have built what I built today by myself
yeah probably but like a it would have
been a lot more you know straining on
you as a person reality is is people we
like to you know associate with other
people we're not Hermits we don't like
this [__] sit in a room I mean some
people do I think it's weird but sit in
your room and be by yourself or you know
your entire life
we like to associate with other people
talk to other people converse with other
people I mean I love living in a
building because I look to see [__]
people every day so I go downstairs my
dorm man my valet like it's great
um I talk to them or every day I ask
them about the families
um so having a best friend and having a
partner in life
got it okay so okay because I think like
those two things you don't necessarily
need to be married in order to do that
don't I'm not saying you need to be
married I mean I believe in marriage as
a whole
um I believe there's a lot of beautiful
things in marriage
um and starting a family
um but no do you need to be married no I
chose that path but I also enjoyed the
[__] out of myself for like the years
before we got married so like not too
many people can say can say that they've
done what I did for the years before we
got married yeah I lived a very young
life
from the get-go then way Advanced I
think more than other people I feel it
so and I have another question for
Maggie too
what if your daughter wanted to do
what would you say really yeah I don't
mind at all she's her own person I don't
have control over her do you believe
that do you believe that it's beneficial
for human beings to have boundaries or
is it kind of just I guess well what are
the boundaries like like if you're so if
your son or your daughter was like yo I
just killed somebody that'd be bad right
yeah of course okay but you don't think
that there's perhaps
um things so like here's what it is like
because we asked that question before
like you know what benefit would it be
or would you want to marry some of the
only fans and I I think like in my mind
I always think like the willingness to
do that to me is is there was something
that happened in the past whether it be
you know the father wasn't there right
attachment issues right like because
it's not like a it's more like a fringe
part of
um Society to me and that's no
disrespect yeah but I think like I would
feel as though I have failed as a father
if my daughter wanted to you know show
her insides online so I guess like I
guess where where's the boundaries or
where's the range like try to help me
understand that
um
I don't know I just like let them know
the consequences and let them like
actually or help them to think about
their future life and not just do it
without thinking what do you think the
consequences are sorry bro I just what
do you what do you think I mean there's
a lot there's definitely like the mental
consequences like psychologically
uh being castorized or rasterized
whatever by Society
um
also like people have a hard time
getting loans for houses if they've done
anything because background checks and
yeah there's just some of them literally
just some of them have you ever had like
a security like where you were afraid
someone was going to stalk you or
anything like that yeah definitely that
also plays it did anything ever happen
like they ever find you not that I know
of I mean just recently I was Doc's like
full legal name ad or like my hometown
on a tick tock really
like scared not because I lived there
but like my mom personal information
yeah exactly yeah yeah said that to me
yeah it's scary you gotta start having
sex right now so I felt unrumbled I was
on see it goes Rumble the other day yeah
what do you think you guys would do
Pearl what would you do if your daughter
wanted to start
no I mean I just
I just think like there's so much other
stuff you could do with your life like
you know like I played Sports
um I just got my mat or I'm in school to
get my Master's Degree like start a
YouTube like there's just so much stuff
you can do without
doing the thing that's like the easiest
well it's the that's the thing is that
here's something quickly is
the natural state of the world is when
you go for easy things and this is my
belief when you chase the thing that's
easy you end up with a much more
challenging life when you go for the
thing that's more difficult and
rewarding it may be hard on the moment
but when you get finally get over that
hump there's this unbelievable Bliss
there's this realtor Ryan Sirhan maybe
some of you have heard of him guy in New
York incredibly successful realtor very
big on social media and he gives this
analogy of when you're going through
tough times it's as if you're rafting
through Rapids and the re the the Rapids
are pushing you back and you're bumping
and grinding and all the you know you're
having a really tough time maneuvering
through the water
if you continue to push forward you
finally get into the open ocean and
you're out in the open ocean everything
is absolute Bliss and it's vast and
incredible and now you can relax and
just take the boat out to sea
and that's how I look at life so in the
beginning there's all this adversity and
all this difficulty and if you can grin
and bear it for long enough and continue
to Pivot and make the right decisions
you end up with a pretty awesome
situation versus if you're selling drugs
you're doing in my opinion it's work
you can go ahead and do it well sex work
is you know only fans isn't illegal so
you won't get arrested for it but you're
ultimately choosing something that's in
a sense easier now I'm not going to say
you I'm sure there's some work involved
obviously yeah there's a lot of work but
uh that's one of my biggest uh
proponents I just feel like when people
cry you know if you want to do she's
still getting married she's coming out
on top yeah
I'm glad you're getting married a lot of
girls don't end up getting married look
at her she's she's getting married this
month I'm happy for you what I don't
like is they come back at 35 and want me
to feel bad when you made this Choice
the last 15 years and now exactly now
you're whining about it it's like but
you weren't whining when you got all the
money the attention all that stuff all
these porn stars coming out and
complaining it's a crazy
yeah I think it just goes back to not
thinking about the consequences and
thinking yeah as long as you know yeah
it seems like you have a very good idea
it sounds like you really do so yeah in
that case Maggie the free spirit yeah
yeah you know if you truly know then
good on you really all right guys is
there anything else I have one more
question go ahead where do you recommend
that girls
fine guys
like fans
Miami Miami
novice
that does only fans that is getting
together with somebody they've done
content with
no I mean we didn't make content
together until after we were dating
really yeah because we were long
distance for eight months so we didn't
see each other wow where was he
Argentina
okay wait yeah so he's not American I
thought you said Miami was the place
yeah this is where we met but your your
guy is from Argentina yeah yeah but the
Miami has just a more open mindset is he
trying to get a green card no not at all
is he is he Argentinian yeah and he's
coming over the EU passport that he has
that's the idea okay yeah I'm trying to
leave America I'm done so you're going
down there all right let's switch up
after the marriage we will try to warn
you okay
real quick let me get this passport
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible